[Music]
good morning at this really very early
hour thanks for coming out
I hope you were able to get a coffee
already it is the sixth time you're
doing this it is likely gonna be the
biggest we might have just a few more
people than we had in 2016 I'm sorry I
was a bit late this time over issues and
reasons and we're in January now which I
hope you'll still gonna appreciate James
Camtasia like every J s conf is a
community event it is for you
specifically for the attendees and we
want to make sure that in this event in
these three days you get ample chance to
get to know each other as well and not
only learn we did this survey online
with everybody who checked in and thank
you for answering all these slightly
funny questions and we asked what is
RJ's comes the best place for to do and
you answered with the vast majority a
great place to meet people so like you
can give yourself a big round of
applause just for that I think that's
actually a good reason to do a
conference so please let's get this
warmed up in general this applause stuff
you need to really get get going over
the day we're gonna have some fantastic
speakers today 24 in total and then plus
a bunch of workshop hosts they bring
their TAS teaching assistants tomorrow
too so they're gonna be a lot of people
tomorrow at the shangri-la and this is
the major change we have this year
compared to the last time we have three
days the middle day is our community and
workshop day the biggest feedback that I
got in 2016 was that the conference was
great but it was really three days of
listening to people and that's not very
interactive is it so that's why we
created this workshop day it's an expert
if you will one that's sold out quicker
than we thought so it's gonna be rather
packed tomorrow be sure you go there
early and it's not gonna be the
shangri-la in the city it's gonna be the
one on sentosa just to make that clear
for everybody also for us you already
went to the wrong one yesterday so
getting to know yourself is the part of
my opening that I want to cover and I
need a bit of help for that I would like
to invite six volunteers randomly
whoever wants to it could be two groups
of three as well if you're friends and
you're just up for some fun it's
literally it's gonna be super friendly
like there's nothing to lose there's
actually only to win we have a few
prizes as well and if there's anybody
out there six people it's gonna be a lot
of people not only the speakers somebody
else too like sure you two gonna be fun
to come out but more people yeah over
here on this table do I have some ladies
as well that would like to join give
them guys some my flaws like we're gonna
build teams yeah carries hello I need
three more people three more people it's
so great to do conferences in Asia
you're all so shy three more people yeah
they're in the middle row with the green
white shirts great and then we are full
I guess yes and we have six people
perfect so would you make yourself into
two groups of three and find yourself a
table please so this microphone should
be on I think so we have Tim you want to
share yourself really quick I'm Tim I'm
speaking here on Saturday everybody
should come along from Australia had a
couple of coffees this morning so I'm
feeling awesome
thank you Tim what is your name
for this this is the second demo from
Singapore amazing correct and then we
have over here carries you go first
i'm karis I flew in from Hong Kong I'm
really looking forward to these days
awesome and then Joe oh I'm Joe I've
been living here and Singapore work for
about 10 years now primarily PHP but
trying to do some nodejs and JavaScript
alright and hi guys my name is Wilson
originally from Brazil live in two years
Australia again I would be I'll give a
talk and three years ago a few hours ago
about micro fronting yeah all right okay
let's get this started
okay Martin ah I didn't hide himself
behind time ninja apparently and the
unicorn know so I'm not very nice
meeting you I'm gonna have a talk on
Saturday as well and a workshop on that
we are in the morning on shangri-la
tomorrow so you definitely want to get
up earlier morning great so we're gonna
do something fun please keep it
respectful and inclusive which is
something we want to keep track off on
this event as well right thank you for
everybody who bought diversity tickets
look around in the room and I think you
can be proud of yourself you helped us
make this place a really colorful and
amazing one so let me just get this
started
all right can I get my screen please
that's great all right what better way
to start than with a game show we did
this before in 2015 we had a jeopardy
DJ's party at the time and I thought
well we ran out of budget in the end and
I had to code something up again so here
it goes
today we gonna play let me restart this
because you want to get this full on do
we have it audio up I still don't hear
anything guys
it's early morning I still make noise
yeah we can make noise we're really good
yeah I try to test these things before
ah there you go I do this one more time
for you just because it's so much fun I
worked on this now
welcome to here we go this is Java too
cute look you know that you don't know
family feud is an American TV show where
two families that we have just created
are gonna compete
meaning we did a survey with a lot of
people and we looked for the top answers
and so you have to guess the top answers
to questions that I'm gonna ask you so
how this works
I will ask from the left to right the
leftist person over to my gameshow board
please so that would be Wilson and your
name was Swamy thank you
let me introduce the teams please
and I'll fade this music out now - so
you have a buzzer here on the left and
on the right so you see we have Team
Unicorn family unicorn is the Wright
family here please give it an applause
for the Team Unicorn and you may try the
buzzer sound there we go
keep the sound up it's nice there we go
alright and we have team kittycat which
is the leftmost table please give it up
for Team Kitty head you might try a
buzzer - Cara right so this is all
working I love it so I have my little
game card here and we asked you during
check-in like a lot of questions and
about 300 of you responded and I sifted
through all of them and I got the top
answers to these so we started with
level 1 which we have here and we are
looking for the top 7 answers your job
is now to find one of them whoever hits
the button faster and get the question
up we're gonna play with your team right
it should the answer be wrong we're
gonna sift it over to the other team and
he gets the chance to steal it
should he be wrong again you get another
chance
if you then don't get it the level has
gone to nowhere okay go for it back we
play with the team afterwards so you
have to find one of the seven top
answers - we asked a hundred people what
is my worst habit while coding unicorn
in context switching context switching
let's see if context switching is one of
the answers and now it is not that means
we'll get to you watching YouTube and I
let's put it in the context of something
else which I think we might have and
that is actually the top answer
procrastinating with 18% of you that
means we gonna play with Team Unicorn
you may go back to the table and then
we're gonna continue with Jo you can now
take a guess on what you think is gonna
be on the board please use the
microphone can you repeat the question
again we asked a hundred people what is
your worst coding habit worst habit
while coding not commenting my code not
commenting my codes let's see if that's
on the board that's correct
nice Karis wrong inventing wrong
indenting let's see if that's part no
it's not so now we go back all the way
to the front
we started with Wilson again you have
three access that you can earn and then
we're gonna go over and they can steal
oh no it's just you it's just you
my worst habit while coding think of
yourself don't write this not writing
test is that one of the answers yes not
testing 8% why not I'm gonna say not
using good coding standards not using
good coding standards see if that's on
the board not on the board not cleaning
up all the mess you made
sagen not cleaning up all the mess you
may not like properly refactoring after
you not properly filling around
unicorn here can actually steal so you
may actually join here and discuss with
your teammates if you are able to find
one answer on the board you can see all
the points okay this is the difference
in game shows you typically have
background music in these situations
right
all right do you have an answer so we
say leaving technical debt leaving
technical debt just admitted people I'm
sorry this round will therefore go to
wait you were team kitty cat those
points great other answers on the boards
were with number two and the audience
may repeat over optimizing number three
over thinking number five copy pasting
number seven perfecting overdoing it all
right now you get how the game works so
I can now get the second player of every
team to come over for the next question
please
so Martin versus toe
yes team kittycat Team Unicorn everybody
okay
we asked 100 people about my last coding
project had too many or too much this
team kitty cat you were first at too
many errors let's see if that's one of
the questions too many bugs they go
fantastic they're gonna play with your
team team kitty cat
the next person of team cat head can
then choose an answer too much code too
much code sound stupid but turns out to
be right very good next one
you can shout into let's make this more
entertaining if you have an idea just
shout it in there is no demo demo how to
use it
my last coding project had too many
demos just checking to complex alright
let's see that's an answer my last
coding project had too much complexity
talk answer fantastic
next one too many libraries too many
libraries whoo let's see how that turns
out too many dependencies that's pretty
good keep it going keep it going
all right I gonna put in a time limit
now - all right next one we start over
with - again - many programmers - many
programmers sadly not it was on the list
but further down Wilson
[Music]
or 18 unicornia time to steal do you
have an idea too many comments too many
comments now at 75 rate level 3 we're
looking for the top 5 answers oh sorry I
sure I can show you so we had on number
one we had complexity number 2 code
number 3 bucks we had number 4 legacy
let's see answer 5 and duplicate code
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
alright level 3 now the last players
please you can always applause in those
moments so keep the hands warm all right
hands on the buzzer please it just likes
that phone oh yeah give it easy we have
200 people I do my best work when we
were first year first of caffeinated
let's see if that's actually a thing all
right we're gonna play with your team
Team Unicorn first time applause for
Team Unicorn you've won that one
me all right what else you start over
here see when the deadline I gonna count
you down
Oh the question again I do my best work
when when the deadline is approaching I
see that's why I was I thought you were
asking when the five seconds are when
the deadline is approaching the pan
let's see if that's one of the answers I
remember it was on the list but it is
not in the top five nobody's watching
nobody is watching
let's see nobody is watching pair
programming
when pair programming with great people
that counts I think it's Martin's
tonight
working on a new project working on a
new project working on a new project
without legacy
[Music]
[Music]
all right team kitty cared with the
chance to steal all the points you just
need to find one of the remaining three
answers and your answer is after I get a
promotion or a raise after promotion or
a raise like that means all those points
will go to a team unit let's see the
Unruh meaning answers and I need you
again audience number one when I'm
undistracted number two
when I'm alone number three when I'm
excited all right
just saying just saying this is fake
news this is a blurry signs okay we have
number four and now back to the first
player again yes let's do some once
again for this thank you
alright we asked 100 people you ready
the worst thing about being a developer
is you need to have an answer when you
press s surprise worst thing about being
a web developer chance to steal the
audience can help it's all your answers
you know the answers if you the worst
thing about being a buffalo face testing
sorry your turn then browser let's even
the bass was a wasting
[Music]
sorry that question goes to nothing so
let's see what people actually chose
from the list you may go back to your
table we start on the bottom to make it
more exciting number five it's a lot of
responsibility number four no gender
diversity all your answers number three
it's unrelatable for others number two
it's high workload and number one
[Applause]
question five the second player of each
team please Allah we asked a hundred
people the first thing that comes to
mind when hearing the word JavaScript is
your first frameworks rainworks
let's see if that is announced a new
how's this
yeah sorry left on you can rescue this
no chair let's Eve no chances on that
list
[Music]
another question wasters let's see
answer number four spaghetti code
[Laughter]
question number three
jQuery number two fun and number one
awesome I mean it suggests up after all
I think you will all buy it all right to
question number six then oh that was on
for six sorry didn't exist here all
right so the next players please and
this is a guest in Crestor thank you for
the applause this is gonna be an
interesting one we asked how many people
I drink how many coffees per week Wow
all right let's see not on the board
none let's see if non zero comma
straight-up answer the tactic we're
gonna play with your team unicorn find
the other answers literally just what I
mean indeed you can you can ask the
audience
is it your turn I think it is okay five
great thank you I've caught Murray's
second Tom Hansen hey next ten coffees
per week this is really good
Tim let's see if you're the Messiah
after all what happens 14:14 is your
turn again I thought it was Tim now oh
sorry 14 and then hit cursed at the
unicorn all right the last level will
settle at all I need the first place
again please join me here for the last
question we're looking for the one top
answer Iran and applause all right we're
looking just for the one top answer and
this is the deciding answer you are so
close in points whoever wins this is
gonna hit it great we asked a hundred
people are you ready when starting a new
fronted project I use sites like atom
unicorn then
Rana is react sure all right let's see
is react the correct answer waiting the
game fantastic and now since we you're
not done yet we're gonna do one final
thing we're gonna do one final thing
because we have prizes but the price is
only gonna be for one of you thank you
so much for playing
that's the handshake yes we may so with
the three of you you may all come huddle
here if you like all around your
microphone we have one final challenge
for you and that's gonna determine who's
gonna take home our prizes now you're
all by yourself now we take the newfound
family back apart so we had one stupid
question in this whole check-in process
some of you might remember and it was
you may click this box now if you'd like
clicking boxes so it's a guessing game
how many percent of the audience do you
think like clicking check boxes eighty
eighty six percent okay great a hundred
percent it's unlikely but okay fifty
percent okay so let's see who is closest
and I will be marching with 17 that's
the closest so Martin you win the final
prize I I thank my family and statistics
101 great so
my mum and dad at home now we get to the
interesting part I'll play you some
music in the meantime you get some hook
not that you need them thank you so much
for playing everybody thank you I hope
you had some fun here all right thank
you so much for participating in this
and I'm now my time is up Hey
this was unrehearsed up with me I don't
think I've to say this but it fits
perfectly so with that I hope you are
gonna have a great three days you're
gonna see me on stage only again on
Friday
like in the very end I guess please
remember one one important thing if you
signed up for workshops and you signed
up for one full day workshop and two
half-day workshops that doesn't work
like you can only take one of those
seeds and some of you did and I think it
was accidental you may find us in the
break or now or whenever at the
registration desk and we're gonna sort
this out because you're currently having
two seeds and we would like to give one
of those to other people that have none
yet so that would be really important of
you if you're unsure please come and ask
at the registration desk we currently
help you there as well so with that
thank you so much for enjoying Javas
confute and I'm gonna leave the stage
back to amazing hosts thank you so much
[Applause]